the Trump administration has done
something that's making some of his
defenders say see look there's really no
Russia story here and what Donald Trump
has done is actually nothing right but
his administration has ordered 60
Russians kicked out of the United States
as a response to what's believed to be
Russia's involvement in the recent
poisoning attack in the u.s. that we
talked about last week maybe even the
week before and to be thorough Russia
still denies involvement in that
poisoning incident but it does seem to
be the consensus of sort of Western
Europe and many of our allies and many
other countries have done something
similar and the Trump administration has
decided that yes 60 people are going to
have to go 12 of those 60 people have
been identified as Russian intelligence
officers stationed at the United Nations
in New York City there's another 48 at
the Russian embassy in Washington DC so
Wow right Donald Trump really taking
major steps to show that he's tough on
Russia in a way that could oh well hold
on a second 14 other European countries
already did this and much more so here's
the deal yeah this is probably the
toughest thing that Trump has done so
far or that his administration has done
so far regarding Russia but the big
picture is that this is peanuts given
what Russia has done number one and
given what other countries have done
with regard to Russia and most
importantly kicking 60 Russians out of
the US does nothing to prevent Russia
from influencing the 2018 midterm
elections which by the way our
intelligence agencies are warning us
that Russia is already in the process of
doing so great kick 60 people out but
what about that election meddling which
the president still it's unclear if he
even believes that that actually took
place so do I think that this is nothing
no it's something but if the idea is
that Trump will heed counsel on this
about the counsel of the House and
Senate which overwhelmingly voted for
sanctions on Russia Russia which the
administration has failed to fully
implement and the other important factor
sort of to bear in mind here is that
Trump still hasn't said anything about
this right the Trump administration has
ordered this and this has no impact
whatsoever on Putin and his goals but
most importantly Trump is effectively
silent on this and his recent silence
also is considered to be partially
related to the stormy Daniels
allegations that have been made and the
idea that Trump is just staying more
silent in general because he doesn't
really have anything to say about that
doesn't want to deny because it would be
all lies
so Putin's goal here bigger picture is
not a surprise right it's so chaos in
the West
so chaos among Western democracies throw
the United States into a circumstance
where they foment six sort of sectarian
I don't know what to call it political
disagreement that escalates into
protests and violence if possible and
make the entire world question sort of
the validity and strength of American
democracy by messing with elections
Putin's ability to do that isn't
impacted because 60 people have been
kicked out period now one thing I do
want to talk about I got a few emails
from people saying wait a second David
it's being reported that these 60
Russians that are getting kicked out are
effectively spies like intelligence
officers if we knew that all along why
were they allowed to be here like why
does the u.s. allow Russian spies to be
in the US a lot of people don't realize
this but this is really common in
diplomatic and intelligence circles
intelligence officers are in foreign
countries as either diplomats sometimes
their cultural attache or legal attache
and it gives them a cover right a
diplomatic cover an ostensible reason to
be in the country but it also can
provide diplomatic immunity
so unless they really get caught
red-handed in something that is very
obviously spying they don't get in
trouble and it gives them more leeway
than just a random visitor to the
country would get and to the extent that
relations are sort of normalized between
their country and the location where
they are doesn't mean we all have to be
allies but if there's normalized
relations we tend to sort of look the
other way we also have agents in their
country they're looking the other way
there as well the other element of this
that I want to point out and I mentioned
this yesterday in my story about John
Bolton is that I don't want to write off
how much of this announcement about 60
Russians might have to do with Trump's
new 3rd national security advisor John
Bolton now John Bolton hasn't yet
assumed the office that happens on April
9th I'm not even saying John Bolton
suggested to trump or to someone in his
administration to do this but what I do
know is that John Bolton who's replacing
from second NSA HR McMaster is both not
particularly Russia friendly and appears
to be someone that Trump is gonna be
paying pretty close attention to Bolton
is known for lack of a better term as a
Russia Hawk and he might go to trump and
sort of delicate delicately say listen I
won't meddle too much in what's going on
with the Russia stuff but there are some
basic things that you should do and this
the expelling of 60 Russian intelligence
officers believe Russian intelligence
officers in accordance with what more
than a dozen other countries Western
European countries are doing this might
be one of the things you just sort of
want to do so we'll follow the reaction
we never want to ignore the possibility
that Trump at any point might go back on
any of this stuff or also we don't want
to ignore the possibility that something
will be said they'll say that they're
going to be doing something and then
that it just won't be done in those sort
of hope that it all gets forgotten which
realistically might happen because
there'll probably a hundred new scandals
before this is even is mentioned again
during a White House press briefing and
that's the next thing I want to talk
about today the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17
a 40% discount off of your membership